I'm actually surprised that this next
story continued to blow up the way that
it has Donald Trump is now demanding
that a pollster apologized to him and
cease and desist because a poll said
that he's losing to Joe Biden and he
doesn't believe that he's losing to Joe
Biden I guess so
this Monday this poll was published from
CNN remember that the CNN poll cNN
polling first of all is not the same as
CNN much the same way that Fox News Paul
polling is not the same as a fox news
broadcast the CNN SSRS poll said that
Joe Biden is ahead of Donald Trump
nationally by 14 points this is a huge
margin 55 to 41 we don't know if this
margin will hold this is just one poll
Trump is furious
so first Trump started tweeting that the
poll is fake on Tuesday Donald Trump
hired some other pollster to write a
letter saying how bad the CNN poll is
including by lying about the CNN poll so
for example the pollster that Trump
hired said that this was a poll of all
adults rather than people who are going
to vote if you look at the methodology
of the poll you see very clearly it is a
poll of registered voters now you can
make the case that a poll of likely
voters would be more accurate but the
poll is a poll of registered voters this
McLoughlin guy falsely claimed it's a
poll of all adults so the debunk letter
was riddled with lies then Donald Trump
started with the legal threats triggered
Trump demanding that the poll be
retracted and that CNN apologized to him
Trump says the poll has to be retracted
because he feels it's not fair or
accurate or well done and that it seeks
to suppress the vote for Donald Trump
now I look back let me get to that let
me get to the suppression a little bit
later the letter that was written to CNN
accuses the network of trying to mislead
voters through a biased questionnaire
and skewed sampling claiming they
released a quote phony poll to cause
voter suppression Trump's cease and
desist letter which threatens legal
action is something I am not aware of
ever happening in this country the
President of the United States threat
legal action over poll results that he
doesn't doesn't like or disagrees with
is completely outrageous this is the
type of thing you might imagine happens
in you know North Korea Venezuela China
Russia places like that you don't
imagine that in the u.s. presidents
threatened pollsters over scientific
polls now it's important for you to know
that this poll is not that much of an
outlier in terms of Trump versus Biden
so for sure a 14-point lead for Biden is
the biggest that we've seen in any poll
so far but if you look at other recent
polls Joe Biden is ahead of Trump by 10
in a few polls by 11 in one poll so 14
is high but it's not like it's
completely crazy where every other poll
says it's a tie or Trump is winning and
CNN drops a poll that says Biden plus 14
when you look at May and June
Biden's winning every poll and it's a
matter of by how much the point is
demanding a retraction and an apology is
bizarre it shows number one again
Trump's a trigger able snowflake he is
he is so thin-skinned number two Trump
is insecure about what's going on with
polling and let me dig into that a
little bit and this is what I was going
to get to earlier Trump claims that a
poll showing Biden is winning will
suppress or is trying to suppress Trump
voters from turning out that only would
be true if your voters don't really like
you that much because in general if I
find out that the candidate I support is
down if anything that makes me more
likely to go out and vote in in other
words here in Massachusetts I'm voting
no matter what in Massachusetts Biden is
likely to win if the polling says Biden
is up thirty in Massachusetts I'm going
to vote because I vote no matter what
but I might be less urgently voting then
if a poll came out and said
Massachusetts in play Trump only down
two in Massachusetts then I'm I mean I'm
voting either way but I'm even more
definitely going to get out and vote
that makes sense so Trump's analysis
that saying Biden is winning is a way to
try to suppress Trump supporters from
voting they must be very unenthusiastic
supporters if they would be moved not to
vote because their guy is losing in a
lot of parts of the country with a lot
of types of people if you see your
candidate is down or that it's close you
are damn sure going to get out to vote
so that that's that now in terms of
CNN's response they said they stand by
the poll as expected that they did the
poll it's a they're a good pollster
that's it imagine ESPN being told hey
you've got a report a different final
score right imagine that the Boston
Celtics defeat the Washington what are
they called down to the Washington can I
forget what that is what are the name of
the Washington it used to be the bullet
the Wizards I'm sorry imagine the
Celtics defeat the Wizards by 10 and
Wizards management calls the ESPN and
says could you report a different score
please because we just don't really
agree that that's the score how does a
Trump voter see this and see Trump as
the alpha male that he claims to be he
doesn't like a poll so he cries and says
everyone's being unfair to him and sends
a legal threat to cowardly move go win
an election
if you're sure that the poll is fake and
then we'll have all the proof we need
assuming it's a fair election which
Donald Trump is trying to ensure it will
not be to be honest I feel like the
presidency of Trump is far more fake
than this CNN poll but ultimately we
will know in five months four and a half
months at this point five months four
months three weeks whether these polls
reflect a rising tide against Donald
Trump or whether he's going to be able
to pull it off make sure you're
following the David Pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show many
exciting things are happening there if
you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way to take control of your
health and get personalized care from
the comfort of your home it's
service called steady MD they're one of
our sponsors you take a quiz you get
matched with a licensed primary care
physician who understands your health
needs you have a one-hour video call
with your new doctor you establish a
meaningful relationship with them and
after that your doctor is available to
you anytime by text phone or video chat
this is not a random doctor on call each
doctor at steady MD has a limited number
of patients so they actually have time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve they can do
almost everything an in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns send
prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy and anything they can't do
online they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example you don't need
insurance it's only 99 bucks a month
with no other fees or co-pays there are
so many practical advantages to using
steady MD for primary care and it's also
so much more affordable go to steady MD
comm slash Pakman to take the free quiz
see which doctor is right for you I took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs in situation the doctor they gave
me is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started just click the
link right underneath this video